in this video you're going to learn how
to find the end behavior of polynomials
so we're going to determine whether the
graph is going up to the right or down
to the right or up to the left or down
to the left and we're also going to talk
about how to describe that and write it
in the proper notation so let's dive
into this video we're going to go
through a few examples together I'll
have some that you can practice on your
own for practice let's take a look at
this first example
so you're already familiar with
polynomials and what you want to do is
you want to make sure you write that
polynomial in what we call descending
order or standard form so you want to
start out with the highest power term
then the next highest powered all the
way down to the constant now what we're
mainly concerned with here is this first
term okay this largest powered term and
what you want to do is you want to look
at the leading coefficient the number
that comes right in front of that
variable here for this first term now if
it's positive
that tells us that the graph is going to
go up to the right if it's negative that
tells us that the graph is going to go
down to the right now you might be
saying Mario why is that well what
happens is as you go to the right here
on the x-axis say for example X is 10 or
100 or a thousand as X gets larger and
larger meaning as you go to the right
this term right here is going to grow
much faster than this term or this term
so for example let's say you put in x
equals 10 10 cubed is a thousand times
five is five thousand which is quite a
large number even if we put 10 in here
this is only minus 200 and then plus 7.
see how those numbers are quite a bit
smaller and if you want to do an even
larger number go ahead and try X as a
thousand and you'll see that this is the
most influential term and that's why the
leading coefficient if it's positive up
to the right negative will make it go
down to the right now what about the
left hand Behavior meaning you're going
to the left end of the graph well here
is where we look at the exponent the
highest
power here so if this is an odd degree
then it's going to go the opposite
direction from the right end behavior if
it's an even degree it's going to go the
same direction as the right end behavior
now you might be saying Mario why is
that
well think of just like an easy example
that you're already familiar with like f
of x equals x squared notice how these
are both going up to the right whereas
when you look at like X cubed one's
going up to the right one's going down
to left they're going the opposite
directions now if this was a negative x
squared the graph would be opening down
but they would be both be going down so
even degrees see they're going to be the
same direction odd degree like if this
is negative X cubed would be going down
to the right but then it'd be going up
to the left so again the degree the
power tells us whether it's going to be
the same if it's even or if it's odd
it's going to be the opposite direction
so now let's talk about the notation
so you can write it this way and this is
usually how they write it in Algebra 2
or even precalculus and if you're in
calculus this is a notation we're going
to use this limit notation
so here it says as X approaches Infinity
that means as you're going to the right
f of x that refers to the Y values are
approaching blank well you can see the Y
values are going up to positive infinity
or you could just write infinity
as X approaches negative Infinity that
means to the left f of x or the Y values
are going down down down to negative
Infinity
or you can do the limit notation the
limit as X approaches Infinity meaning
as you're going to the right f of x or
the Y values go to infinity or you could
say positive infinity and the limit as X
approaches negative Infinity you're
going to the left f of x so the Y values
are going down down down to negative
Infinity so you can see the same answer
just a different way of writing it now
one little caveat or warning is that
oftentimes teachers are on tests they'll
actually put the left end behavior first
because you know when you read this
graph you're basically reading from left
to right like this and so it'll
oftentimes put this first now I always
like to look at the right end behavior
first and then the left hand Behavior so
you could do them in the opposite order
but just kind of be cognizant of what
you're doing
let's take a look at a number another
example number two now notice I put some
notes here if you want to write these
down or take a screenshot
a is our leading coefficient greater
than zero that means positive you're up
to the right if the leading coefficient
a sub 1 is less than zero that tells us
we're going down to the right that means
it's negative evens it's the same
direction to the left as it is to the
right and if it's odd it's the opposite
so just some little notes there for you
but for number two what do you think for
this one is it going up to the right or
down to the right
well you can see the leading coefficient
is negative so that tells us that it's
going to be going down to the right
okay even degree see it's a force degree
is going up to the left or down to the
left even degree tells us it's going to
be the same way so down to the left so
in this case when we write our notation
as X approaches Infinity
f of x or the Y values are going down to
negative Infinity as X approaches
negative Infinity f of x or the Y values
are approaching also negative infinity
or if you're doing your limit notation
the limit as X approaches Infinity f of
x approaches negative infinity or the
limit as X approaches negative Infinity
the Y values are approaching negative
Infinity let's take a look at a few more
examples okay what do you think for
number three and four how would you do
these ones so for number three we have f
of x equals x to the eighth minus two x
to the fifth plus four now remember
these guys are like to throw us off a
little bit these really don't have any
influence on the end behavior they're
going to come into play when we go to
find our our zeros and the shape of our
graph Etc like that but for now just
talking about the right end behavior in
the left hand Behavior we're going to be
using What's called the leading
coefficient test right and we talked
about that already so in this case you
can see the leading coefficient is
actually understood to be a one and it's
positive so that tells us it's going to
go up to the right
the degree is an eighth degree that's an
even number that tells us it's also
going to go up to the left so when we
write our notation as X approaches
Infinity meaning as X is getting bigger
and bigger f of x or the Y values are
going up towards positive Infinity
whereas as X approaches negative
Infinity we're going to the left f of x
so the Y values are going up up up also
to positive Infinity now if we want to
use the limit notation limit as X
approaches Infinity
f of x approaches infinity or positive
infinity and a limit as X approaches
negative Infinity f of x is also
approaching positive Infinity
okay so what do you think for number
four
f of x equals negative 10 x to the
seventh power minus three x squared plus
five what do you think on that one is it
going up to the right down to the right
up to the left down to the left
well if you forget everything about this
entire video okay you can always go back
to that technique I showed you at the
beginning you could pick a number for x
and it doesn't matter what number it is
you could pick a 10 100 a thousand you
could even just put in positive one if I
put in one here one to the seventh power
is one right times a negative 10 is
going to be negative 10. so you can see
where it's going down right or if you're
not convinced by that put in 10 10 to
the seventh power is how much like 10
million right so then times a negative
10 that's like negative 100 million
you're way down here right
and then if you put in a negative 10
okay so you're over here to the left
negative 10 to the seventh power now a
negative ten seven times that's still
going to be a negative number times this
negative is going to make it a very
large positive number so that's it
you've got it if you don't like that
method you could say all right leading
coefficient tells me about the right end
behavior it's negative so I'm going down
to negative Infinity
and then because it's an odd degree I
think odd opposite like o for odd o for
opposite odd opposite
so that's going to positive infinity and
same thing here the limit if you want
the limit notation as X approaches
Infinity you're going to the right the Y
values are going down to negative
Infinity however as you're going to the
left towards negative Infinity the Y
values are going up towards positive
Infinity
let's take a look at two more examples
see if you can do these on your own okay
take out a sheet of paper see if you can
pause the video and do these last two
examples on your own and we'll go
through them together see if you can get
these right
so for number five we have f of x equals
negative one half x to the sixth plus X
cubed minus two
and what do you think for this one is it
going up to the right or down to the
right
leading coefficients negative means
we're going down to the right
even degree six is even right same
direction to the left so that means
these are both going to be negative
Infinity left end behavior and right end
behavior just remember the as X
approaches Infinity that's talking about
the right end behavior negative Infinity
is talking about the left hand Behavior
okay how about for number six f of x
equals eight x to the fifth minus two x
to the fourth plus three x squared plus
one what do you think on this one up to
the right or down to the right up to the
left or down to the left what do you
think well leading coefficients positive
that means it's going to go up towards
positive Infinity to the right meaning
coefficient always tells us about the
right end behavior odd degree that
exponent is five odd means it's going to
go the opposite direction to the left so
let's do our notation here as X
approaches Infinity meaning as we're
going to the right f of x the Y values
are going up to
positive infinity or if you're doing a
limit notation the limit as X approaches
Infinity f of x or the Y values are
going up towards positive Infinity now
if you do limit it or as X approaches
negative Infinity you're going to the
left f of x or the Y values are going
down down down towards negative infinity
or the limit notation the limit as X
approaches negative Infinity the Y
values are going down to negative
Infinity
so let me put a video right there on the
screen that you can go to talking more
about how to actually get a better graph
here so we're going to talk about how to
find like the shape of the graph and the
end behavior and the x-intercepts and
dive a little bit more into graphing
polynomials so I put a video right there
for you follow me over to that video and
we'll get some more practice I'll see
you there